MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to Root Access, the show
for start-ups on Google
Developers Live.
I'm Martin Omander, and I'm
joined here by Googler and
longtime investor and start-up
evangelist Don Dodge.
Today we're going to talk about
setting up a company.
So Don, I often get
this question.
When in the life cycle should I
form a legal corporation for
my start- up?
DON DODGE: As soon as you can.
It's important to have a company
to be able to accept
money, to be able to hire
people, to extend offers, to
own assets.
So you want to have a company
set up as soon as possible.
It can be a simple, little
corporation.
It can be an LLC or a Sub S
corp, but you should have
something with a bank account
as soon as you possibly can.
MARTIN OMANDER: So as soon
as you possibly can.
Does that mean before the
friends and family round that
we talked about in
earlier episodes?
DON DODGE: Yes.
Again, you need a company
to accept money.
You need a bank account
to put the money in.
So you mentioned earlier
about Larry and Sergey.
They didn't even have a
company put together.
So when an investor wanted to
write them a check, he wrote
it to them personally,
because they didn't
have Google set up.
I don't advise doing that.
It worked in their case.
MARTIN OMANDER: It
worked for them.
DON DODGE: Quite well.
But it's better to have a
company set up and a checking
account set up, so that you can
pay for things that you
need and accept money
as soon as you can.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
And seeing that checking
account statement does
something to your-- it reminds
you that you have a company,
too, I guess.
DON DODGE: Exactly.
Every month when that checking
account statement arrives, it
reminds you, yes, I'm in
business, and yes, I need to
be doing things.
I need to be hiring people.
I need to be setting
up my website.
I need to be building my app.
So it's another little reminder
that this is serious.
You're starting a company.
MARTIN OMANDER: We're
actually doing.
So you mention LLC, S
corps, Sub S corps.
What should a start-up
founder do here?
Do you recommend what type?
DON DODGE: Yeah.
It depends on how quickly you're
going to accept money
from investors.
But typically, start-ups lose
money, maybe for the first
year or so.
So you can set up an LLC,
or what's called a Sub S
corporation.
In both cases, the losses from
the company flow through to
your personal return.
So you can actually take a
deduction on your personal tax
return for the losses
of the company.
Now that changes when you accept
money from an investor.
Then you have to be a
full C corporation.
But it's easy to make the
transition from LLC or Sub S
corporation to a full
C corporation.
It's fairly easy to do.
You can do it yourself,
if you want.
But if you're not comfortable
with that, then you should
have an accountant
or a lawyer.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
And even if you may be
comfortable doing that, you
should focus on your start-up
idea, perhaps, and not so much
about figuring out these
different types of
corporations and such.
DON DODGE: Yeah.
Well, you can do Google searches
and find the answers
to most of these questions
online.
And most of the things that you
would need from a lawyer,
for example, Articles of
Incorporation or IP assignment
rights, or hiring kinds of
agreements, employment
agreements, you can find
those things online.
And they're pretty
boiler plate.
But if you're too busy or not
comfortable doing that, then
it's good to have a lawyer
who can do it.
And they'll do it relatively
inexpensively.
Because those are fairly basic
things, but they're things
that need to be in place.
So either do a search and find
them online, or get a lawyer
to help you with them.
But there are things
you must do.
You cannot have a company that
creates value where you don't
have employment agreements and
IP assignment rights and Board
Articles of Incorporation.
Because things get messed
up in a hurry.
So those are basic things that
you need to have done before
you accept money from
investors or
before you hire employees.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So what other infrastructure?
We mentioned checking account.
We mentioned think through
what type of
corporation I'm creating.
Is there other basic
infrastructure like that that
I should have in
place early on?
DON DODGE: No.
Not from a legal or accounting
point of view.
Those things are pretty basic.
You can run a company out of a
checkbook for quite awhile.
As long as you have a checking
account where you can accept
investment or accept revenue
from customers and you can pay
for things, you don't really
need to have much of an
infrastructure for
quite awhile.
When you take on friends and
family money, you can still
run it out of a checking
account and be fine.
When you accept money from angel
investors or venture
capitalists, then you've got to
have more systems in place
to be able to handle
those things.
So it's pretty straightforward.
But having an accountant or a
lawyer that you can call on
when you need them is probably
a good idea.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you have that
relationship in place and
you don't need to go
look for them.
DON DODGE: Right.
You don't want to be having to
stop what you're doing and go
do all of this, when the
business is growing and you're
moving along.
Take care of that stuff in the
early days, when things aren't
quite as hectic.
MARTIN OMANDER: Early
is better.
All right.
Great.
Thanks, Don.
That's all for today.
Please add your comments and
questions for the YouTube
video, and we'll get back
to them in future shows.
Thanks for joining us
and see you out the
next time, next week.